in our series the new normal will take a
look at how the pandemic is dramatically
changing
our everyday lives this morning we're
taking you inside a look at what
classrooms could look like
if schools reopen this fall now some
districts plan to have smaller class
sizes less movement through the schools
and fewer visitors
meg oliver is inside an elementary
school classroom in parsippany
in new jersey meg what can parents there
expect
gail good morning they're still
finalizing their plans here but this is
what a typical classroom used to look
like with connected desks and 23
students in a class
but if you walk across the hall this is
going to look like in the fall
half the number of desks with dividers
spaced
six feet apart everyone must wear a mask
students will also eat their lunch at
their desks but they won't be able to
leave
anything behind including books and
school supplies
i'm confident today that we can reopen
we have six weeks to go sebastian powell
principal of eastlake elementary in
parsippany is spending the summer
preparing for his school's reopening
the blue line right now is basically a
lane that you're going to have so that
you're walking one way
on one side of the hallway the school is
set in a middle class new york city
suburb
almost 10 percent of the students rely
on free or reduced breakfast and lunch
at schools
so you're going to have half of the
classroom on each week the students will
come in one week
they'll be here for four days and then
they'll go to distance learning the next
week while the other cohort comes in
how is that fair
not really fair but it is safe sending
half the number of students to school
each week reduces class sizes from 23
students to 11.
that small class will stay together all
year
buses which used to carry 52 students to
and from
school will now board just 22 outside
visitors will be limited
and the school will close for a thorough
cleaning every night
the teacher will most likely be doing
the instruction from here
you know if she needs to navigate the
classroom
she can do so but still needs to
maintain a distance it's kind of sad
looking at this
it is not optimal but once again is
keeping the
safety first i would not step into
school
not to decorate not to collect my things
andrea basemore a 27-year-old first
grade teacher in dallas
contracted covet 19 a few weeks ago she
is refusing to return
to a classroom it is so disheartening to
see so many
teachers and all of the teacher groups
that i see putting together wills
having that conversation with their kids
about
what happens if i die daniella and bond
benton from west orange new jersey
are college associate professors they
say remote learning took a heavy toll on
their family
their oldest daughter is autistic and it
got worse over time she really secluded
herself off from the world completely
how important is it for your daughter
who's on the spectrum to have in-person
teaching
i mean it's everything because because
she relies on the interaction with the
other person
in tulsa oklahoma the holmes family
won't risk sending
their two youngest children back to
school both parents are
immunocompromised
my husband hasn't been at work since
march so
we literally have been living off of
just my disability
but the technology to support more
remote learning comes at a cost
and some difficult choices it may be
whether this month we pay the light bill
or water or gas we may have to put it
off
with so much uncertainty principal
powell is sure
of one thing his students can return to
school
in a safe manner basically it's just
like any other lesson we're going to
teach the kids
the safety and ensure that you know they
know what they're doing and i think they
will adjust fine
here in new jersey every district will
come up with their own plan
now here if anybody contracts
coronavirus they will work with the
local health department to trace
contacts
but it ultimately will come down to the
superintendent whether to decide to shut
down the school
tony boy meg i'm with you it's a little
sad seeing a classroom like that i think
the takeaway is
if kids go back to school it's not going
to be school like we recognize from our
childhoods it's going to be very
different indeed
thank you very much